[Music]
come on man it's brand new
happens when it happens
i've got my cowboy hat on so i'm a
cowboy let's say that i mean yeah i'm
involved uh it's about me but um they
stay where they stand
dak prescott with the cowboy hat he's
got the star on the helmet still
remember the dallas cowboys under
contract for one more year they're not
gonna let him get them away next year
they'll use the franchise tag at least
once or twice if it comes to that but
shireen one of the big questions in
dallas continues to be will they get
this contract worked out last week it
was the carson wentz deal and that
sparked some reporting from clarence
hill regarding the notion that maybe dak
prescott's agents want 34 million a year
for prescott and i don't think that's
all that unreasonable of a number
especially when we talk about a new
money analysis because when you look at
the full contract it would be about 27.6
million per year on a five-year deal if
it's a four-year extension worth 34
million per season puts him in line with
jimmy garoppolo and kirk cousins he's
better than both of those guys he's
accomplished plenty he's played in every
game that his team has had there's
something to be said for the durability
he's been to the playoffs twice he's won
a playoff game i thought he looked very
good in that game against the rams even
when the running game wasn't there
usually the running game has to be there
for prescott to be there that was one of
those occasions where i saw prescott
play well without the running game
playing well so i think the arrow's
pointing up for prescott
i just i i you know i just feel like the
cowboys hold over him and really anyone
else who they're negotiating with the
idea of playing for the cowboys and they
expect people to recognize there's an
inherent value to that and to take less
money in order to continue to play for
the cowboys
the cowboys have always gotten deals
done that they've wanted to get done and
i believe as jerry jones believes that
they're going to get this deal done but
i think this is the hardest deal they've
ever had to do and they are looking at
that salary cap and they are looking at
the fact that they have to pay amari
cooper and ezekiel elliott and byron
jones perhaps leaves because they don't
have money to pay him and jalen smith's
going to come up in another year from
now so they've got all these players
they're going to have to pay if they're
going to keep this team together this is
one of the best young teams on paper in
football but to keep them together
you're going to have to find a way to
fit all those guys under the cap and
it's going to be really really hard and
steven jones has talked about that
that team
friendly deal and i just don't know if
they're going to be able to or how
they're going to be able to do that and
get it done uh with dak but i'm with you
i don't think that price tag based on
new money is unrealistic it's what the
market bears and you want to keep this
guy you think he's your franchise
quarterback that's what it's going to
take to keep him
yeah agents love the new money analysis
because it makes the deals look better
than they otherwise would look but a guy
like dak prescott loses out when you
obsess over new money because he's only
due to make 2 million this year so that
34 million per year when you throw the
two million that he's due to make this
year it does drag the full average down
to 27.6 million which isn't nearly as
impressive as 34. and i think it makes
it harder for the cowboys to justify
getting to a 27.6 million contract on a
five-year average because maybe they
don't want to be tied to the idea that
they're making him such a highly paid
quarterback and that may cause others to
want more money than maybe they want to
pay i mean you have to balance it out
just right and that's where the new
england patriots benefit from having a
quarterback who consistently doesn't try
to blow out his potential earnings and
create havoc for other positions on the
team because what happens is you
eventually have a bunch of highly paid
players and then you can't afford the
depth and when someone gets injured
you're pressing into service an
undrafted rookie who may or may not
perform as opposed to having two or
three million you can spend on a veteran
backup who used to be a starter
somewhere else who can come in and play
and you don't have to worry about that
spot and and the cowboys are inching
toward that territory with all of these
star players they have to pay and and
dak is the one who's going to command
the most and it's quarterback position
it should command the most
dax quote my favorite quote that he's
had throughout this whole contract issue
was when he said somebody brought up tom
brady and he said yeah but i don't have
a wife who's a supermodel who makes more
than i do and that's true and it's a
it's a great point and i don't think
he's going to settle for a team-friendly
deal in the way the cowboys want him to
settle for a team-friendly deal and and
they're going to have to figure out how
to get this thing done and maybe it's at
the expense of ezekiel elliot maybe it's
at the expense of of byron jones as some
of these players that they would love to
keep that they're gonna have to let walk
but the good thing for them is they have
drafted over the last few years since
will mcclay became involved heavily
in the front office they have drafted
extremely well and so that's going to
help them if they do have to let some of
these players walk away they're going to
be better off yeah i think dak prescott
more important to the cowboys than
ezekiel elliott even though elliott is
the guy who who really emerged and
helped give that offense the the kind of
kick that it needed to make it easier
for prescott to do what he needs to do
it's easier to find another ezekiel
elliott than it is to find another dak
prescott i know michael irvin's been
very passionate about this and his
comments to the media that you've got a
great quarterback in dak prescott you
don't let him go you find a way to keep
him around now tony romo would always
take less than maybe he could have
gotten he never tried to push it to the
limit i feel like dak is more inclined
to push it to the limit and dak isn't
listening to the idea that hey you're
the cowboys quarterback you're going to
sell more jerseys and make more money
that way you're going to have
sponsorship deals that wouldn't be
available to you if you were the jaguars
quarterback you're going to have a
broadcasting career waiting for you when
you're done like a tony romo a jason
witten a troy aikman because you were
the cowboys quarterback
i think that between prescott and his
agent they don't care he's got value as
a quarterback other teams are paying the
cowboys should pay and this concept of a
team-friendly deal
i just don't think that the team is
going to get that and the question is
will they blink and pay prescott what he
wants or would they dare
to run the risk of not having dak
prescott and trying to find another
quarterback somewhere else i i i just
think shireen they're going to do
whatever they have to do to keep him
oh no question and you know jerry
one of his favorite lines is i don't
have enough time to have a bad time and
you look at his age and the fact that he
does want to win another super bowl
before he dies how long it's been since
this team has won 1995 was the last time
they even went to the championship game
when they won the franchise's fifth
super bowl and it's it's been a really
long time and and jerry knows that his
window is open now but it may not be
open for
who knows how much longer so he wants
the win now and the way to do that
is with dak prescott rather than going
out and trying to find a quarterback
they tried that after troy aikman and it
took forever before they lucked into
tony romo and finally found tony romo
and now they've lucked into dak prescott
and they haven't had to have that
waiting period for a quarterback they
will pay him they will keep him it may
be at the expense of some other players
including ezekiel elliott and byron
jones and you know what they may have to
do is just let him earn two million
dollars this year
as uh the fourth year on a fourth round
contract and then franchise tag him in
2020 franchise tagging again in 2021 and
at some point they're gonna have to pay
him the problem is the longer you wait
to pay him the more expensive it's going
to be because other guys are going to be
paid now is the time to do it and right
now of all the guys out there who are
eligible for second contracts the
quarterback position now we know marcus
mariota and jameis winston they
deliberately haven't gotten their second
contract because the teams don't know
whether or not they want them to be
around beyond this year but dak prescott
and jared goff are the only other two
young quarterbacks out there who are in
that spot where they could get a new
contract their teams i believe want to
keep them around they made that decision
this is the guy the question is when do
you do the deal and it will get more
expensive the longer you wait whatever
that number is now for dak prescott it's
going to be higher next year and the
only way it gets lower is if he gets
injured or if he just has a dramatic
drop in his play and i think we've seen
enough from him in three seasons to
believe that he he will only get better
and he won't get significantly worse and
and shireen look i don't know what this
new offense is going to do for him i
don't know how much better the offense
is going to be
but you know you look at a dak prescott
and you wonder how much better he would
have been over the last three years if
he was in an offense that is a little
more diverse a little more imaginative a
little more unpredictable in what
they're going to do
at any given moment maybe his numbers
would be much better than they've been
through three seasons
well on the fact that he only had amari
cooper for nine games as well dez bryant
was at the end of his career when dak
had him and he finally now has a feature
receiver a guy who can make plays and
you trust can make plays you're going to
get the ball to him in any circumstance
and you saw his yards per attempt rise
in the nine games that he had amari
cooper significantly rise in those nine
games and i think those two are only
going to get better they had a great
offseason together they figured some
things out together and and it snapped
right away for amari but i think he's
going to be even better in this offense
this season than he was in those nine
games last year when he had to learn on
the fly and the interesting part
obviously for the cowboys is kellem
moore what's he going to add to this
offense how is he going to change things
how's the offense going to be different
and and that's to be determined and i
don't even know if we're going to know
that in the preseason but we're going to
see it a little bit but i saw a lot more
motion out of the cowboys and some
different things that they did moving
players around uh in the off season
workouts so i do think that's going to
be a significant difference for this
team
and amari cooper another one of the
cowboys that needs to get paid at some
point by the way we're scheduled to talk
to a mark cooper on monday he's doing
some work on behalf of gatorade so we'll
get a chance to ask mark cooper about
how things are going in dallas and
whether he thinks he will have that new
contract in place when the regular
season begins
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports